Okay. It has only been, like, a week since my first video,
and he is already so much heavier and bigger.
It's crazy. He growing so quick.
Um, that's something that I didn't realize before getting a dog.
Like, I knew a lab was gonna be big. Okay.
And he had huge paws as a puppy,
so I knew he's gonna be big,
but I didn't realize how quick he would grow.
We've had him for, like, two. No,
we've had him for, like,
three weeks now,
and I feel like he's, like,
tripled in size.
He's huge.
So, yeah,
we'll see. We'll see if we can still do the song
in, like,
seven weeks from now.
I don't know if we're gonna be able to.
Can you say hi?
Hi, friends.
He's such a well behaved dog.
We've worked really hard to try and train him so that he,
you know, can sit and he can lay down.
He's gonna come.
He doesn't really know his name yet.
That's the thing that I thought he needed to learn first.
But his name is Hank,
and I don't think he really knows it.
He's just the sweetest pup.
He's really good with our kids.
Oh, that's the Hank update.